Maps can contain a lot of information,
so it’s important to guide readers’ attention
to the most important elements. In this video,
I’m going to explain how to do that by
establishing what’s called visual hierarchy.
The basic idea here is very simple: how much
attention readers give to different elements
on a map depends on the visual appearance
of that element and the ones surrounding it.
As an example, I’ll use this map of
personal robberies in San Francisco.
On this basic version of the map there are
two layers: one showing hotspots of robbery,
and a base map that helps readers
understand where those hotspots are.
On any map the most important layer is the
one showing the data we are interested in.
Because that layer is the most important, it
should also be what’s most visually prominent.
In this case, I’ve achieved that by using a strong
colour for the robbery layer while choosing a base
map that uses shades of grey. Since brighter,
more saturated colours – or colours that have
a greater contrast from the background – are
more visually prominent than shades of grey,
this helps the robbery hotspots
stand out from the background map.
Colour is just one way that we can influence
the visual prominence of elements on our map.
We can see this if we add some supporting
elements to this map, such as a title and
the names of local police districts. Now there
are several different types of text on the map,
it will be useful to help our readers understand
which is most important. You can see here that I
have used text size to make the map title more
prominent than the text on the map itself,
which is in-turn more prominent
than the copyright statements at
the bottom. I’ve also made some of
the text a lighter shade of grey,
which makes it less visually prominent by reducing
the contrast between the text and the background.
Another way to increase or decrease the
visual prominence of a map element is to
use isolation. Elements that are isolated
from their surroundings, such as text that
is surrounded by a box of a contrasting colour,
or points that are surrounded by a thick line,
are more visually prominent than the same
element without that isolation. Similarly,
if an item is semi-transparent, that will
tend to reduce its visual prominence.
It can be useful to combine
attributes such as size,
colour, isolation and transparency to create
multiple levels of visual prominence on a map,
helping to guide readers to the
content we think is most important.
Whenever we are making decisions about how
to represent different features on a map,
it’s really important to make sure that the data
layer or layers is the most visually prominent,
since that is the layer readers need to focus
on most to make decisions. All the supporting
elements on a map – administrative boundaries,
base maps, labels, copyright information and so
on – should be less visually prominent than
the data layer to avoid distracting from it.
So in summary,
Creating a visual hierarchy helps guide
readers through the maps that we make
We can establish visual hierarchy
using combinations of size,
colour, is isolation and transparency
We should always make sure that the data layer
is the most visually prominent part of our maps